it's time to put away the horse rhetoric
we have to stop treating our opponents
as our enemies they are not our enemies
they are Americans that made everyone
feel kind of warm and fuzzy well what
did Biden sound like today
something dangerous happening in America
now
there's an extremist movement that does
not share the basic beliefs in our
democracy
the Maga movement there's no question of
the day's Republican party is driven and
intimidated by Major Republican
extremists
their extreme agenda if carried out
fundamentally all of the institutions of
American democracy as we know it
the only thing I was missing is what he
had last year that real weird red light
background I mean the fingers always
pointed back at Democrats when they
accuse conservatives of being this or
that it's what they actually are and
right now yeah the threat to democracy
is coming from people trying to lock up
the guy who's leading in the polls in
the opposition party
so they don't want to empower the people
but they do fear the people and they're
going to smear the people and lie about
us to seize more power for themselves
that's the great danger and a second
Biden term joining me now Ned Ryan
founder and CEO of American majority and
Ben demetich Fox News contributor and
editor at large of The Spectator Ned um
this really did feel like it was a redo
of his Independence Hall speech a year
ago which didn't work then but they seem
to be going back to the drawing board
I mean nothing says bipartisanship uh
when the president United States tries
to demonize half the electorate and
Laura I got to tell you for any normal
rational clear thinking human being in
America it should be deeply troubling uh
that the president United States is
trying to demonize tens of millions of
people but not only demonize them
dehumanize them and I think you don't
even have to be a close student of
History to understand that those with
authoritarian Tendencies uh use this
rhetoric to try and dehumanize and turn
these people into sub-humans and once
they can do that and these people the
percentage of the population is seen as
sub-human you can do it do to them
whatever you want and that's deeply
troubling and I think the life's
authoritarian Tendencies their language
their behavior that's an existential
threat to America's way of life and
their freedom and the other thing that
was very troubling to me it's not
America First trying to destroy American
democracy we're not the ones trying to
censor Free Speech or the free flow of
information we're not trying to censor
anyone we're not trying to use the legal
system as a weapon again against our
political opponents over policy
differences that would be Joe Biden in
the left and their definition of
democracy has absolutely nothing to do
with true representative democracy and
that's very apparent from what Joe Biden
said today well Ben when I'm listening
to uh Biden today and I'm thinking he's
essentially saying that if he doesn't
win and his people wrote this he's just
reading the lines I'm sure he doesn't
even understand it at this point but he
said if he doesn't win
then America is essentially a rogue
Nation
that's quite the message to the rest of
the world at a very dangerous time for
the world
even the energy in those two clips that
you just showed Laura was very different
you know one of them he seemed like he
was struggling to kind of read off of
the teleprompter in front of him you
know the other he seemed to be far more
you know attuned to what was going on
and I think that's kind of an indication
of the decline that we're witnessing as
a nation uh you know in this president
who is just you know holding on to power
grasping it white knuckling it to the
end without any kind of regard for the
fact that he no longer has the ability
to function as our commander-in-chief in
any real way look I I found this to be a
completely uh you know depressing
objectionable speech the kind of things
that the demonization that he is engaged
in of a significant portion of America
essentially half of Americans it's
totally at odds with the kind of things
that he promised when he was running for
the presidency the first time and it's
consistent with the kind of partisan
demagoguery that we have seen from this
white house which just seeks out you
know to to find people to blame for all
the problems that are at hand as opposed
to engaging with their own flaws though
their own flaws of bidenomics their own
flaws of of inflation and everything
that it's done to people's pocketbooks
they just won't engage with it they
won't address it as being honest and in
instead they're engaged in this complete
fantasy world where they are always the
heroes and everyone else is to blame for
the problems yeah I mean I mean I think
Biden and his team would much rather
deal with the CCP on pretty much any
issue than ever deal with any of the
conservatives on the hill I mean they're
they don't want to the conservatives are
they're they're kind of like as Ned said
sub-human but China you can work with
that's a twisted that's a twisted
Outlook all right Ned um Trump was
speaking to the UAW members very smart
yesterday uh to try to you know again
solidify the working class base he
wisely brought up
um Biden's EV mandate what it will do to
the Auto industry check this out
for Auto Workers Biden's Force
transition is a transition to hell if
your union leaders will not demand that
crooked Joe repeal his electric vehicle
mandate immediately then it doesn't
matter
what hourly word you get it just doesn't
make a damn bit of difference because in
two to three years you will not have one
job in this state
yeah and then it doesn't matter what you
get in these negotiations your jobs are
going to be toast especially with the
encroaching China threat with the EV
industry and Manufacturing
well exactly Laura I mean it's it's not
a coincidence that the Biden White House
is so charitable and dovish towards
China especially on this electric
vehicle and solar solar panel solar
power uh which would all basically give
a lot of power uh over the electric
vehicle and green energy business to
China it would make us heavily Reliant
upon them I mean it really is if you
want to look at us a much broader
picture Beyond electric vehicles and all
this it's a national security issue if
you're going to actually take these
parts of our manufacturing and give it
over to China significant portions of
our life and really let them truly
control it I think you're endangering a
lot of our our way of life our jobs our
manufacturing but also giving China a
lot of power over which direction this
country is going to take not a shock at
all from Biden's White House doing this
um Ben before we go Biden was at this
event in Arizona I guess to honor
Senator John McCain
by building a library and Senator
McCain's name now I know this is
personal to you uh and obviously to your
wife but what can you tell us about this
what I can tell you Lara is that the
idea that you would take coveted relief
funds and use that to build a library
for Senator McCain would be an extremely
insulting thing to Senator McCain
someone who regardless of your opinion
of his uh you know perspective on
foreign policy his ideology on you know
any number of things was emphatic as a
fiscal conservative an opponent of
earmarks and a believer that you should
not have pork spending and slush funds
the idea that you would take money from
a coveted Relief Fund in order to create
a library is ridiculous you could
absolutely have raised this money from
his former donors you know I was talking
to Senator Lindsey Graham earlier today
about this very point it's something
that could have been done and instead
Joe Biden parachutes in and wants to get
the the you know the the plot it's from
The New York Times and others for being
a defender of democracy by doing
something like this this with a
ridiculous source for the funding
involved it's absolutely abhorrent I
hope that some uh you know folks in the
Senate who actually have fiscally
conservative principles will claw this
money back it should not go to something
like this and John McCain would not be
in favor of it neither am I neither is
my wife Megan and I'm sure that that you
know many supporters of have who respect
him for the fight that he had over pork
spending would be in that same position
as well all right very interesting we'll
be following that as well Ned and Ben
thanks so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else